look it's like this this movies messed
up and I like messed up ready or not
here I come so ready or not is a fun
kind of funny yet morbid thriller with
dark humor the premise is this guy in
this girl they're getting married the
girl's marrying into a very wealthy and
eccentric family they have a tradition
on the wedding night they play a game
with the new bride and that's like the
initiation to be in the family what's
the game hide-and-go-seek
a really deadly game of hide-and-seek
yeah she hides they find her they kill
her let the games begin this movie was
great I really dug her the only thing
that would have made this movie better
is if I didn't know about the movie like
the movie had no buzz online before I
saw it it was just this weird little
surprise that I saw this did not have
that luxury this will select oh by the
way there's a really good movie I think
you'll like it cuz everyone loves it it
is deadly game of hide and seek it's
cool though it takes place in this
enormous mansion so there are a zillion
places for her to actually hide in that
keeps it fun but also these morons in
this family it's not like they do this
every night peace these weapons are
really archaic I don't wanna say too
archaic but like crossbows and axes are
a couple of really old guns it's just
funny when they like you have anything
from this century and there are a couple
of scenes in particular that were just
way too intense movie has more humor
than I thought it would have in it but
when it wants to get down to it's like
alright we're getting down to business
the intense scenes are still really
intense and I understand the humor in
this movie this movie took itself too
seriously
what kind of killed it for me I don't
think every movie should have humor I
think more movies have humor then should
have humor well for this movie it did
work at a point there was this one stick
that kept happening and I was like in
retrospect I'm either gonna see it as
brilliant or it's just gonna be that
weird awkward out of place thing that
kept happening and in retrospect looking
back it actually really does work for
the movie and don't recognize the lead
star in this movie but she's really good
like when you first see her you're like
oh it's just kind of margot robbie ish
I'm looking at her IMDB I don't really
recognize her from anything her name's
Samara Weaving hope to see her more
stuff and when you first see her you're
like are her eyes CGI she's most eyes
cut right through so I like the main
protagonist you're rooting for her her
husband he's kind of caught in the
middle it's like I want to help my new
wife but I'm kind of bound to the family
I found that compelling but special love
to Adam Brody in this movie he's amazing
I don't say he made the move
but he's the best character in the movie
he's just doesn't give a [ __ ] he's like
he's the inevitable outcome of any sane
human being who's a part of this family
most people in this family's like their
eccentric [ __ ] who obviously are
okay with murder
he's the realist he's grounded in
reality and it broke him every scene
with him in it I'm like yes more at a
point in the third act I was like you
guys are really gonna need to stick the
landing for me and they did I thought a
completely worried guys in the end ready
or not was great it was fun it was funny
it was dark it was messed up it was
thrilling it did this weird balancing
act and by the end even when it was like
okay are you gonna work yep you do
imagination went into this movie I
really appreciate that it's one of my
favorites of the year honestly it was a
good time but also a unique premise or
if it's not a unique premise because
we've had movies with maniacs trying to
kill people in houses before and really
big mansions before it was a unique
execution of this premise I will say
ready or not is worth watching and worth
buying on blu-ray or 4k or ultra
high-def whatever I recently upgraded to
4k that you'll see in my July journal
that I'm coming up with very soon now
I'm like I can't go back once you see it
so to upgrade the rating I don't know
all right so ready or not have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you liked what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]